THANK YOU, SIR, FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
GOD BLESS YOU.
>> Tammy: HAVE A GOOD TIME AND
TOLLS THAT.
TULSA IS ONE OF THE CITIES
RESISTING THE CALLS TO DEFUND
THE POLICE, BUT ELSEWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY THE RADICAL LEFT IS
GETTING EXACTLY WHAT IT WANTS
AND HALTS ARE WALKING OFF OF THE
JOB.
THE ATLANTA POLICE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED A HIGHER THAN USUAL
NUMBER OF CALLOUTS, IN OTHER
WORDS, A WALK OUT.
NYPD OFFICERS ARE BEING
ENCOURAGED APPARENTLY TO CALL IN
SICK ON THE FOURTH OF JULY AND
THAT WOULD BE KNOWN AS THE "BLUE
FLU" AND SPREADING TO OTHER
CITIES AS WELL.
POLICE AND PHILADELPHIA,
TALLAHASSEE CONSIDERING WALKING
OUT INTO AN ME NOW IS A WOMAN
WHO HAS THE BEST PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT THE POLICE ARE FACING AND
HAVE BEEN FACING, HEATHER
McDONALD, MANHATTAN SHEEP
FELLOW AND AUTHOR OF THE
APPELLEE NAME "THE WAR ON COPS."
HEATHER, WELCOME ABOARD.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON TO
ME, YOU APPRECIATE IT.
>> Tammy: WE SEE A DYNAMIC IN
A LOT OF WAYS THE MOOD OF THE
POLICE ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS
DOWN FOR UNDERSTANDABLE REASONS.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE FOR DEMOCRAT
MAYORS AND CITY OFFICIALS
BECAUSE I THINK IN GENERAL,
DEMOCRATS DO CARE ABOUT THEIR
CITIES.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE.
WE HEARD THAT IN THAT LADIES
CALL FROM CHICAGO.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE FOR PEOPLE TO
STAND UP TO THE POLICE OFFICERS
WHICH PROVIDE SOCIAL COHESION IN
EVERY CITY WHETHER BLUE OR RED?
>> I THINK YOU ARE BEING A
LITTLE TOO GENEROUS.
IT TOOK ABOUT THREE DECADES OF
INCREASING CRIME IN
NEW YORK CITY FOR VOTERS TO
THROW OUT THE EXISTING
DEMOCRATIC POLITICAL STRUCTURE
THEY ARE AND BRING IN A MAYOR
THAT ACTUALLY DID CARE ABOUT THE
LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES
BEING LOST IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITIES AND A LOT MORE
POWERFUL AND PHARAOH’S INTEREST
IN BEING REELECTED.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO THE POLICE
IN THIS COUNTRY, IT TAMMY IS
TRAGIC AND OUTRAGEOUS.
THEY ARE LIVING UNDER THE EFFECT
OF A LIE AND ALL PAINTED RACIST,
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST.
THEY RALLY REALITY IS WE DON’T H
A POLICING PROBLEM BUT A CRIME
PROBLEM.
THE POLICE AND THE NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
VICTIMIZED.
THAT IS WHERE THE DRIVE-BY
THINGS ARE OCCURRING.
THAT IS WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE
BEING SHOT IN THEIR HOMES AND
THEIR BACKYARDS AND THE POLICE
DON’T WISH THAT UPON THEM BUT
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY TURNS
THEIR EYES AWAY FROM THEM.
HERE
THE COPS ARE UNDERSTANDABLY AND
INCREDIBLY DEMORALIZED.
NO OTHER PROFESSION LIVES UNDER
THE BURDEN OF THIS HATRED.
AND WHAT THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
ON THE STREETS RIGHT NOW WHEN
THEY TRY TO MAKE AN ARREST,
PEOPLE ARE INTERFERING.
THEY ARE THROWING THINGS AT THEM
AND CURSING AT THEM.
IT IS COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDING
BUT THEY ARE BACKING OFF BECAUSE
THEY ARE TOLD IT IS RACIST
TO TRY TO PROTECT LIVES OF THE
MINORITY COMMUNITY.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE.
>> Tammy: ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
I HAVE TO SAY, HEATHER, AND I
LOVE THE POLICE AND LAW AND
ORDER KIND OF GAL, BUT WHEN YOU
DO RETREAT, THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE HEARD FIRST ARE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
YOU GOT THEM CALLING THE POLICE
AS MUCH AS ANYBODY ELSE’S.
THEY DON’T HAVE MONEY FOR
PRIVATE SECURITY.
THEY DON’T HAVE GATED
COMMUNITIES, IF YOU WILL.
AND SO THAT CONCERNS ME A
LITTLE.
BUT IT IS AN ATTACK BUT
NEW YORK, IT IS A SINGLE PARTY
CITY.
LIKE LOS ANGELES AND CERTAINLY
CHICAGO IS A DISASTER BECAUSE
IT’S BEEN A SINGLE PARTY CITY
FOR 140 YEARS.
ISN’T THIS REALLY ABOUT
LEADERSHIP?
IN THE MESSAGING IT SENDS TO THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE POLICE?
IF LEADERSHIP DOESN’T RESPECT
THE POLICE, WHY SHOULD THE
PEOPLE RESPECT IT?
>> IS ABSOLUTELY ABOUT
LEADERSHIP.
THESE LEADERS CAN ASK THE POLICE
CHIEF, TELL ME THE REALITY OF
CRIME.
THEY CAN BE OUT THERE IN THE
POLICE ARE NOT RACIST.
WE NEED THE POLICE.
THE COMMUNITIES NEED THE POLICE.
INSTEAD, THE LEADERS ARE
PANDERING TO THE MOST RADICAL
ELEMENTS IN THEIR CITIES, AND
THEY ARE SELLING OUT TO
THOUSANDS OF LAW-ABIDING
COMMUNITIES.
SO WHAT IT IS GOING TO TAKE, I
DON’T KNOW, TAMMY.
IT IS A DILEMMA, BUT AS I SAY,
WHAT ARE THE COPS SUPPOSED TO
DO?
THEY ARE TERRIFIED THAT THEY
WILL RUSH TO JUDGMENT LIKE
ATLANTA.
COMPLETELY UNJUSTIFIED MURDER
CHARGES.
AGAIN, THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
FROM A SMALL SEGMENT OF THE
COMMUNITY EXTRAORDINARILY
CONTEMPT.
THEY WORRY NOW ABOUT MORE
SHOOTINGS.
I’M TERRIFIED MYSELF THAT WE
WILL SEE A LOT MORE ATTACKS ON
COPS.
YES, THEY DO BACK OFF BECAUSE
THE MESSAGE THEY ARE GETTING
MOST UNEQUIVOCALLY FROM THE
MEDIA IF YOU ARE RACIST IN THE
MINORITY COMMUNITY.
>> Tammy: FET IS ONE OF THE
DIFFERENCES MEDIA OF
PERPETUATING PERSONS WHAT THE